[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
the thing I love
most about being a developer
is that I get to actually solve
real-world problems, and I can
do it without any special tool
then.
So I can just open
up a text editor,
put my code in, and then
start to actually see
the problem being solved
in front of me as I go.
MALE SPEAKER 2: What
I enjoy the most is
the bleeding edge,
the speed at which we
deliver new technologies.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Our community
is based on sharing,
and we do open source.
And by passing our work back
and forth, we all get better.
MALE SPEAKER 4: [NON-ENGLISH]
MALE SPEAKER 5:
Having every client
be connected to
the web at any time
is both a blessing and a curse.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: The biggest
challenge developers face
is there is so much information.
There are so many different
tools, technologies,
and resources for
them to choose from,
and they're not always
the easiest to find.
MALE SPEAKER 6: Things
used to be a lot simpler.
We used to write code and
we used to compile it,
and then we would be done.
Now, we've got the
web to worry about.
We've got mobile to worry about.
And then on each
of these platforms,
there's separate tools.
MALE SPEAKER 7: Some
days you're just
like, I just want
to build, and I
don't want to kind of
bridge all these gaps.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Even
if you stay on top
of all the releases and
all the API changes,
trying to figure out how
would a developer use
this to provide value
to users out there,
that is also stressful.
MALE SPEAKER 8:
What I really hope
we see over the next,
maybe, five years
is that people get access to
good connectivity, cheaper
data.
Through that, they get
access to the whole web.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: There are
millions more people coming
online throughout the world.
And for developers, it
presents a huge opportunity not
just to expand, but
to think about how
to build custom experiences
that match the unique needs
of those new markets.
MALE SPEAKER 2: If
we're going to have
the same pace of innovation,
there are no signs
that it's going to slow down.
It's going to be a really,
really exciting future
out there.
MALE SPEAKER 7: There's
so much opportunity,
and you see so many unexpected
things every single day.
MALE SPEAKER 5: We connect
to everyone on the planet,
and that, to me,
is just amazing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]